Hey look at this!  There's a broken canister of
mutant ooze leaking down into the sewers.  I got a
little too close, and this mysterious goo is all over
my hands now.  But don't worry because this sticky
slime is non-toxic, and it's so easy to make a 3 year
old can do it!
All you need for this project are some common
household items you probably already have.  A little
Borax detergent booster, yellow and green food
coloring, and a 5 oz bottle of some clear non-toxic
school glue like this one.  First we'll need to
measure out 1 cup of water, and carefully add 1/2
teaspoon of Borax.  Stir that in as best you can, and
now we'll need a separate bowl to hold 1/2 cup of
water.  This is the part where you can take the lid off
your glue bottle and dump the entire thing in.  Stir
the glue and water together so you get a good mix,
and grab your food coloring because we're going to
use 2 drops of green, and 5 drops of yellow.  The
yellow is going give this a slimy yellow-green look,
so stir it all together, but don't touch yet.  It's only
when you add the Borax mixture into the bowl that
the gelled ooze starts to form before your eyes.  You
can try and stir it together now, and what you're
going to find is a great green glob of flubber.  This
slime is so shiny, so stretchy, and so gooey and
green that it's nearly irresistible not to put it in your
mouth.  Luckily it's non-toxic and doesn't really taste
bad, but it's probably better if you kept it in your
hands.  When you can transfer your slime to a
different bowl, there will be a little water left over,
and that can be thrown away.  This stuff looks pretty
wet and sticky, and if you're not careful, it can get
everywhere, but if you dump it out on something like
a table and let it flatten out, the whole thing is firm
enough to pick up and flip over, like a pancake.
Because we used clear glue, the slime itself is
transparent, and when you hold it up in front of a
light, it resembles some kind of alien experiments.
That's kind of creepy.  We're going to need a way to
store our slime, and I tried putting it back in the glue
bottle, but this old Play-doh container is much
better.  One batch actually filled both these
containers.  But I want a canister that stands out.
This looks like it should work.  It's just a couple of 2"
ABS clean out adaptors and plugs from the
hardware store, and some left over acrylic tubing.  If
you want to make this at home, there's a good
chance you don't have any acrylic, so I'm going to try
and imitate this with a clear 2L bottle.  First I'll need
to empty this bottle, and my wife really likes this
method.  Then after it's cleaned and dried I'm going
to grab some scissors.  I'm cutting off the bottom, the
side and top pieces so that I get this nice rectangle
sheet of plastic.  It naturally wants to roll up into a large
tube, so I'll use that to my advantage by placing
both ends inside the ABS adaptors, and letting it
expand.  I decided to use hot glue to try and hold
this overlapping bit together,  then remove the caps
and continue with the rest.  I'm just using the plugs
on the ends to keep the tube the right size as the
glue cools.  I also added some glue around the
edges to make it all a little stronger.  Now hot glue
can go on the ends, and the adaptors twisted on
overtop to ensure good contact with the glue,
making this an ooze-tight seal.  Well it's not as
perfect as a acrylic tube would be, but it's free!  Now
our slime can go inside, and when the cap is on, it's
actually looking pretty good!  The clear plastic
allows the ooze show through, and the ABS fittings
give it a more authentic look.  How do you think
your neighbors might react if they happened upon
something that looked like this?  Would they call the
police?  It's non-toxic and dissolves in water, so
should be pretty easy to clean up.  Just for fun, I
went to the dollar store and got some yellow glow
sticks to put inside.  I'll break them up to get the
chemicals mixing, and shake them until they glow.
When I push one of the rods into the center of the
ooze, it glows an eery green light.  One is enough,
but I'll try two and put the cap back on.  I like how
this is looking.  You can lay this glowing mutant
ooze down in dark corners and people will have a
hard time figuring out what it is.  Well that was a fun
project, and a favorite new toy.  If you like these
videos, click here to subscribe and select to be
notified when I upload my next one.  Hit the thumbs
up button, share with your friends.  I appreciate your
support.  Thanks for watching!